hello and welcome to movie clips  mixology Oscar edition today we are  making a flaming moneymaker cocktail in  honor of the Leonardo DiCaprio  oscar-nominated film the wolf of Wall  Street  here's what you will need martini  glasses a shaker a shot glass for  measurement Goldschlager Bailey's Irish  Cream rum  butterscotch schnapps ice and for the  rim powdered sugar  first for the rim dip your martini glass  in water then powdered sugar  next add ice to your shaker  add one and a half ounces Bailey's drop  in one and a half ounces of butterscotch  schnapps lastly add 3/4 ounces of gold  shocker  mix up the ingredients in the shaker and  strain into your glass next you will  pour 1 tablespoon rum into the side of  the glass so that it sits on top to get  that flashy wolf of wallstreet look  grab your lighter and set your drink  ablaze a little wallstreet drink has to  be flashing